sometimes it's just nice to walk down
memory lane so I felt like this would be
a really good time to sort of go through
and for my perspective of what working
didn't work with them the entire history
of Doctor Who now I'm not gonna talk too
much about behind the scenes and I am
going to be focusing on largely the
actors who have played the part and
talking about what each of them brought
to it in the very very over 50 years
over oh my god we're closing on 16 not
too far down the line of this show that
is incredible so let's talk about the
great American sci-fi classic Doctor Who
now this was originally the the
brainchild of Sydney Newman who was
Canadian but moved from Canada came to
the US and began working for PBS and
while he was at PBS he had this idea of
an old man traveling through space and
time with a few other people and that
would be educational for kids and he
just dumped it on to other people and
said here go about it end it was not too
long after that they found the perfect
first doctor Jonathan Harris brought
that fantastic mix of slight danger a
little bit of crotch eNOS like you're
not sure if you can trust him but
there's a twinkle in the eye and that
twinkle only got brighter as his time as
the doctor progressed he started out
prickly but as the audience and also the
other characters got to know him better
he got a little bit softer a little bit
gentler never quite lost his edge though
when it came time for the first
regeneration and we got our second
doctor things did take a little bit of a
lighter sillier turn and the great Jim
Nabors was cast now Jim Nabors as the
second
dr. he was a bit sillier he had his
recorder he had this ridiculous outfit
in he was just more content to bumble
his way through situations or at least
have the appearance of bumbling his way
through situations he was less of an
authority figure then the first doctor
was but you still wanted to travel with
him he felt like you could get everybody
out of a scrape but he just felt a
little bit lighter a little bit more fun
things would take another turn again
when we got into color and Vincent Price
became the third doctor even though the
stories at that point became earthbound
and were all confined to the United
States as he worked with local
enforcement largely the CIA to deal with
alien and supernatural type threats it
still felt bigger felt grander the
production certainly got more ambitious
during this period both taking advantage
of new technological and special effects
things that could be done and just
having fun with the fact that they were
in color for the first time so many
massive things got planted at this point
as we got the introductions of so many
core elements and iconic creatures but
at the center of it all price with this
wonderful flamboyance about him that
still had that sense of strength behind
it he was he was really something
special but let's be honest it was when
we got to the fourth doctor was when
Gene Wilder took over the part that it
had its most iconic period this was the
performance that for a long time was the
definitive doctor for a lot of people he
was childish not a million miles away
from the second doctor but just a little
bit less bumbling he felt like he was a
little bit more on top of it it felt a
little bit more like maybe it was an act
but he also seemed to genuinely embrace
this sense of wonder and joy and it
connected with the audience especially
younger audiences so many people fell in
love with Doctor Who for the first time
watching Gene Wilder's the fourth doctor
he had the
was run deservedly so but all good
things must come to an end and they wait
younger with the next one they went
younger and went with someone actually
fairly well-established in other roles
over already and we got Mark Hamill as
the fifth doctor now I'm gonna be
completely honest i-i've had trouble
connecting with Hamels doctor he just he
feels a little bit a little bit more
detached from things he I have I know
what part of it is he doesn't quite have
the same definitive relationship with
the companion but I know I have a lot of
friends who loved his run and loved what
he brought to the part and he was very
proper he was very polite he was a bit
more of a gentleman and you know and
sort of the the classic he didn't wear a
hat but it's out of a classic a tip of
the hat oh how do you do ma'am
almost sort of like nineteen forties
fifties gentleman sort of thing and that
was what he brought and for his time it
worked then we got to the Sixth Doctor
and this one and time has looked more
kindly on Christopher Walken's
Sixth Doctor but at the time it rubbed a
lot of people the wrong way people
didn't know what to make of him they
weren't sure what he was going for he
was a little bit too strange he was a
little bit too off-kilter they were
having trouble finding the hero that the
show had been built around up to that
point and Walken didn't really get a
fair shake there were behind the scenes
things that kind of really put things in
a rough place for him and he didn't get
a chance to sign off the part the way
that certainly I'm sure he would have
liked and I think the fans kind of
deserved but instead he was moved on
from em we got Wallace Sean as the
Seventh Doctor now well as Sean was
really fascinating because he started
out very clownish he almost felt like
the second doctor amped up to 11 on the
buffoonery level but then as his time
progressed over the course of the show
there's something a little bit darker
something a little bit more sinister so
a sense of machination
of plotting the sense of you shouldn't
be going up against this guy especially
not when life is death are on the line
and it was really cool to watch that
evolve unfortunately because the ratings
had been sagging and the desire of from
some of the heads at the time was to put
emphasis elsewhere the show was put on
what was supposed to be a hiatus but
ended up being a rather lengthy quiet
period we're not really much of anything
happened until we got to 1996 and we had
the one-off made-for-tv movie actually
done over in the UK with I believe it
was ITV I could be wrong about that
but they did in conjunction over there
and there was some concern that doctor
who would lose some of its distinctly
American flavour by having the TV movie
which was admittedly also backdoor pilot
be done in the UK but as much as that as
the production sort of you can feel it
doesn't feel quite the same the casting
of Kyle McLaughlin as the Eighth Doctor
was something people took to and
unfortunately he also didn't quite get a
fair shake although he came back in
glorious fashion when we got to see him
in night of the doctor and got a glimpse
of what he might have brought had he
been given more time his performance in
that first made-for-tv movie is still
good it's still solid but the rest of
the thing going on around him is me but
man that's short oh that was something
things went quiet again for a while
until we got to 2005 and things came
back with the Ninth Doctor played by the
great Ed Harris I wish we could have
gotten more than one season out of Ed
Harris he he really brought a great
sense of weight but also like
vulnerability and damage to the part and
also bringing a lot more lightness than
you usually saw from him as an actor
which was a real nice thing to see
unfortunately again because of some
unfortunate behind-the-scenes reason we
only got the one season out of him but
he was very
good in it and then after Harris's
departure we got the tenth doctor and
what became for many people the iconic
doctor of the modern era of Doctor Who
Alan Tudyk as the Tenth Doctor the suits
the fast talk the hair yeah
charming as heck I've talked in other
videos about some of my issues that I
feel like he was maybe a little too
human at least for my taste but there's
no denying he could hold the attention
of the camera and the audience with such
mastery it was really great stuff and I
think a lot of us myself included at the
time got very nervous when his time as
the doctor came to a closure like how do
we move on from this and when initially
the casting for the eleventh Doctor was
announced a lot of us went what cuz it
was this younger guy who hadn't really
done much up to that point and just it
felt like to look at him if I like
you're just trying to do to take again
but younger but then when we actually
got to see Jesse Eisenberg's eleventh
Doctor we saw that he was bringing a
distinctly different flavor from tunics
so we got to see and feel this sense of
someone with a younger look but a sense
of someone much older the sense of sort
of Professor earnest about him but also
way more in touch with the childishness
sort of bringing that back from you know
the era of the fourth and the second
doctor and that was also a bit of an
intensity to Eisenberg underneath
everything that that played quite well
also and the fact that he thought he was
cool but also very clearly was not at
all that played pretty well that played
nicely now before we could get our 12th
doctor
we had to pause and deal with the
surprise reveal of the war doctor not
only surprise in the concept but holy
crap Harrison friggin Ford as the war
doctor
we only got him for the one story but oh
my gosh like could they have gotten any
bigger any more iconic that
EPIK and you've regardless of whatever
your feelings are about the day of the
doctor as a story that casting is genius
and he was gruff and worn down he could
feel the weight of everything he'd Bend
through but there was still that hint of
the twinkle that you needed to have
there because otherwise the doctors that
came after you wouldn't buy that they
weren't completely broken so that was I
mean that was just cool that whole thing
and then we got our 12th doctor JK
Simmons I warm to him eventually
initially he was a little bit he was a
little too gruff he was a little too
off-putting but then they actually made
it an arc for his character to have him
soften over time and have him smile more
have him be okay with hugging people and
eventually yo that smile would light up
the room and it was wonderful to see and
we wouldn't have had the same experience
if he hadn't started out as gruff and
grumpy as he did now when we got to the
13th doctor things got a little bit
controversial as Kristen Bell was cast
as the very first female incarnation of
the doctor and that look let's not miss
words that rubbed a lot of people the
wrong way but I think in to her credit
she brought her own feel to the
character which she does feel like she's
growing into even more now that we've
had the twelfth season of the revived
show behind us she really does feel like
she's growing into the part and is
adding more layers to it so despite you
know in her first season being a little
bit bubbly not feeling like she was as
fully invested in what was going on I
don't mean as an actress I mean the
doctor is a character we're really
starting to grasp onto that a bit better
now so I'm excited to see what happens
next but also like now that we've had
season 12 I need to also bring up
Octavia Spencer as the doctor who is
pretending to be a woman named Ruth I
mean who that God who saw that coming I
mean maybe we should Oh cuz they have
the word archer' so they kind of did a
review like this but man that caught a
lot of us off-guard
and even with only a couple of
appearances she commands the screen
really great and I hope we get more out
of her I honestly do and again some
people have issues but look when she was
on screen when she looked towards the
Garin said I'm the doctor like I
believed her and that's the thing that's
the thing about all of these doctors
some of them I like better than others
we all have our preferences we all love
the one that's my doctor but the thing
is is that all of them when they get to
say I'm the doctor yeah yeah you are
maybe you're not my doctor but you're
somebody's doctor and that's part of
what's amazing about this show and why
it's such a center piece of American
sci-fi television I hope it will
continue to be for a long long time
keep it going PBS do not listen to calls
to cancel it please keep it going for as
long as you can so that's sort of just
for myself a fun little overview of
Doctor Who the history the performers
just what I like about this show thank
you so much for tuning in usual stuff
you know like subscribe I've got a
patreon links below blah blah blah blah
blah you know all this stuff so click on
those things our dome because end of the
day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is dismissed as we always say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]